[Music]
hey guys i'm in vegas and i want to give
a shout out to my sponsor helix sleep
find your perfect mattress at
helixleek.com and have the best sleep of
your life
okay welcome back we're i'm on the road
this is the special edition of ripping
with griffin special like short bus
special yeah
part three the poli shore experience the
third time on the podcast do i have the
record or the least amount record um no
you don't have the record yet but you're
close you're one of the few people that
have been on this many times you know
the last time we were what are you doing
because you've been with me all week and
i haven't gotten any on my social media
okay so the last time uh i spoke to you
it was like overzoom the pandemic it was
like in the middle of it and you had
moved to hawaii
well i wouldn't say i moved there oh
yeah well i was staying there for about
three months yes yeah but that's that's
a pretty significant yeah yeah that's a
that's a pretty significant move and now
you're out here in vegas
um
i don't know like what like
how is it for you now like you know this
stage of your life
uh you know you're still doing stuff so
your career is still going you know
that's great you know that's that's
probably the blessing when you think of
vegas you always think of like on the
back side of people's
careers but yeah but you know but it's
not like you have like it's not like
it's like paulie's yours at caesar's
palace at the bingo room no no you
actually moved here for life reasons
yeah definitely
no i just um i've been coming to vegas
since i was a kid right you know my dad
lived here for many years oh i didn't
even know that yeah my dad my dad passed
away here in vegas about two years ago
right in summerlin right there so my
dad's widow lives here i have a lot of
friends here my friend jason strauss
lives here who runs half the night life
in town i got a lot of new friends ryan
who's shooting this right there he's a
good friend of mine we became very close
i've been here for about a year
and um i just wanted to for me i wanted
to be around a new beginning and just
kind of
i know you might not think this because
i don't know what you know vegas but it
makes me happy here like i feel happy
and joy here you know what i mean like
there's a joyous here that reminds me
of the early part of my career
when i was doing a lot of silly stuff
and and to me vegas represents goofy i
mean we were on the street you saw that
knucklehead come up yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's a knucklehead yeah you know he's
from um yeah you're just like crazy so
i don't know um
vegas is fun it's silly it's fun my
brother scott got a place out here now
so he's going to be out here and it's
only a 45-minute flight from la yeah
yeah you're in l.a all the time i see
you in l.a all the time yeah but like
how is it
how is it at this stage of your life
because i'm not even saying career i'm
saying this is your life because you've
had such an amazing life really i mean
you had a there was a ginormous career
time in your life where it was like
may everybody knew who polly shore was
yeah you know and so now
are you you're in are you do you feel
like you're enjoying the fruits of that
labor now like how
how would you consider what's happening
in your life right no i definitely feel
like i'm in my 20s again you know you
even look around my my house here it's
just silly it's just like you know well
it looks like many porn shoots have gone
on here before you moved in
and during and during my movie
no i don't know i got this house you
know i didn't buy it i'm leasing it
because i don't know where my head's
going to be in six six months i don't
know what i'm saying no one knows what
the [ __ ] going on so you might be in
idaho next time i see you yeah actually
i was thinking about idaho no i don't
know just you know when your parents
pass away and you get a lot of that you
know and you're going through stuff with
your family and you kind of move on you
want to just kind of move you know
switch a new leaf and kind of
get in a new space and la is my heart
and la's my home but this is where i
live right now
yeah yeah but i feel like
well let me ask you do you feel like any
place else but la though you know
because there was obviously something
that made you be like i gotta get out of
l.a
was just i've been there 50 years yeah
so it was just like [ __ ] i got to get
out of life because of that and then the
coronavirus and all that [ __ ] had a lot
to do with it
la's just [ __ ] it's depressing now
there's like there's like a um
um a feeling there where everyone's kind
of resistant there's no like there's no
like freedom i don't feel freedom there
i feel like this kind of like everyone's
you know kind of being watched and
everyone's like this
it's just the opposite of la to me ever
yeah it just feels weird if to me it's
just so bizarre here that a place where
it's like
24 7 drinking you can walk on the street
with a beer uh prostitution's legal uh
you know uh there's pawn shops you know
you're gambling there's this is a place
about addiction and debauchery
but they want you they they wanted to
act like they care about people's health
with the coronavirus yeah i mean that it
just seems bizarre to me like here in
terms of like you know they just
restarted the mask restrictions like
saying you don't want to be doing that
for political reasons because the
governor says to do it because you know
that's just the way it is now but
there's no capacity like so you could
still be like you know it's like you're
indoors everybody wear masks but there's
no social distancing there's no
like
there's no there's no capacity like you
know things just not la la's la la is
the only place i think in america that's
really like
you know like what you're talking about
you know what i mean like well it seems
that everybody you go to texas florida
all those places are the same way i mean
i just did a tour of texas it's the same
thing people don't give a [ __ ] yeah you
know so it's just it's strange i was i
was talking to ryan before this i was
just saying like i feel like
um you know we're going to be able to
get back to normal life when we start
looking at the that covet the way we
look at alcohol and i'm not saying
they're the same but i'm talking about
the feeling that we have towards it is
that we really just don't you know we
don't care people take their own
personal responsibility i mean i know
that like i said i know it's not the
same but i'm just talking about the
feeling towards it because you know when
you look at alcohol related deaths
it's it's astronomical a number you know
uh when you look at like obesity like
the leading cause of death in the
country it's obesity you know it's like
it's obesity related diseases you know
like we don't look at those numbers like
oh my god what are we going to do about
this we just kind of go well this is
part of our society and then we move on
with life i think when we get to that
with kovid that's when
life is going to get back to normal
because right now it just it just feels
like like we don't really know what
we're doing or why we're doing it and no
one does really because you you get all
these people saying you know fouchy or
this one or that one and then stuff
constantly changes yeah it keeps
changing it's like changes and you're
like [ __ ] you know at the end of the day
you know you're sticking [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] veins that you know what the
[ __ ] it is but you're rolling the dice
and you're saying like hey the
scientists and the smart smart people in
the world are telling us this is what
the [ __ ] to do so we just do it and then
the people that don't do it
that are getting sick
you know that's that's on them
you know that's on them yeah i'm not a
anti i'm not an
anti-vaxxer or if you're anti-vaxxer
anti-mask that's your business do you
but the problem is they're letting that
affect
our lives our world yeah and i'm like
come on man you told me to get the
vaccine and i did and i'm ready to live
my life and now all of a sudden i can't
yeah the people that don't get vaccines
if they say that you know if if they say
you're not allowed to go in a certain
restaurant then you shouldn't get mad
just say those are the rules right now
yeah yeah the rules right now is you
have to have that card that basically
says that you've you've been injected
with the serum [ __ ] that i don't know
what the [ __ ] it is i'm starting to
freak out from it i don't know like what
are you talking about no i'm just i'm
fine from it now yeah i got it did you
did you have enough did you have any did
it hit you at all when you took it
what
no uh yeah it did it [ __ ] me up pretty
bad for like a day or so really yeah
didn't affect me at all
yeah well that's because you're already
you know [ __ ] up
anyways use that as a clip for a thing
no i'm just kidding
no you know what's interesting is you're
hearing a lot of people that are getting
the coronavirus after they've gotten
vaccinated i know more people that have
gotten vaccinated here's the big
question is then you the first thing you
ask them is like what vaccine did you
get and then they say johnson and
johnson and you're like yeah well that's
why and then they said pfizer and like
yeah that one's pretty [ __ ] up too so
the only one that i have not heard that
they got the corona virus after they got
seen was the madonna bro that's why the
wheeze got the materna
what'd you get are you getting sponsored
by what it's just this this podcast is
sponsored by madura what did you get the
weezer strains did you get the pfizer no
i got the pfizer yeah i want to see if
you guys get the visor
that guy probably has it [ __ ]
no but john lovitz got it and he had the
pfizer yeah but he's john lovitz yeah
he's crusty right he's he was the
original paulie shore
no i don't know i mean i i've been doing
like a bunch of like uh health stuff you
know i lost about 40 pounds and you know
i get regular like iv shots i get those
iv drips you know i get like immune
boost iv drips
i do stuff like that you know you know
very much like i was like very much like
whoa what's going on here i don't want
uh you know and plus my mom has dementia
so that's like that also made me be like
all right what are some of the causes of
dimension it's like high cholesterol
inflammation and these types of things
that you can actually cast with polly
sure yeah
these are the kind of things that like
you have to like look out for yourself
so i started to do those things but i
think that being healthier
is also one of the things that helps you
combat covet in the first place in
cocaine addiction yeah well i don't i've
never
you didn't have a cocaine addiction did
you no but we could got some in the
other room
of course vegas baby vegas baby oh
no
the gps on the tracking on this video
they're going to come right knock on
your door they've been here before i get
it from them anyways listen so i think
you're right i think you know you want
to uh my mom had dementia and
alzheimer's and parkinson's and all that
[ __ ] and yeah you want to try to avoid i
think i think a lot of it has to do with
just besides eating is just stress
levels
your blood pressure goes up when you're
just constantly
that and i think with my mom
i think that her the reason why she
started to get the shakes because it
started i think in 2000
is because of the business
because my mom is an artist she's more
of an artist as opposed to like a
business person and she was doing both
to understand she was being an artistic
person you you know like creative but
then she also to deal with the insurance
and the [ __ ] building and all that
[ __ ] and that to me is what [ __ ] her
up
you know there's a picture of my mom
right here we went to monte carlo
and this was it was
she was sad dude this was a sad photo
of her when i went because we went to
visit peter my brother peter was in um
it's a beautiful shot yeah it is it's a
beautiful shot but she was you know kind
of depressed
very emotional my mom was very emotional
[ __ ] i think she was probably in her
i'd have to say maybe
early 60s
damn you know be that stressed at that
age yeah you know what i mean and and um
yeah it was just uh and i think going
back to what you're saying
is that um
is that when you get you know you get 40
50 60 years old
you want to try to you know
you know i like waking up and having no
emails
you know what i mean i like waking up
and like i do a joke on stage i got a
burp one sec
i do a joke on stage where
where i say like i'm playing downtown
fremont street down here and so you know
it's a it's a pretty ghetto kind of like
dirty area of vegas but i play into that
and i say this where polly show wound up
you know
at the grand hotel the delirious comedy
club in fremont street i said you know
adam sandler's making 20 million a movie
and i'm [ __ ] you know and i'm pop
locking on fremont holding the
strawberry daiquiri and i said i think i
won you know what i mean yeah because
sandler's making millions but he's got
all this stuff to deal with and like me
i'm kind of like i don't want to say
semi-retired
but my pressure is just yeah you know
what i mean and that happens when you
get older you just you just you know
people call me up to do things all the
time let's you know want to do this do
this i'm like you know what it's how
much time is this going to take up on my
day because at the end of the day that's
all we have is [ __ ] your uh at the
end of time all we have is the day is
your day and that's it and like do you
want to spend four hours working on some
[ __ ] app
or some [ __ ] you know
you know some weird thing that you know
it's not even really in your lane or do
i want to be able to write jokes and go
[ __ ] around my dog or whatever and that
stuff that's where i'm at at 53. yeah
you know i find that like when every
time i'm around you or
you know we have interactions or you ha
you're doing something it's always
something that's like it's silly
but i can tell you're really enjoying
yourself yeah and you surround yourself
with like people that like i can tell
like there's no stress yes
yeah that's kind of like that's i'm glad
you picked up on that that's kind of
where my head that's why i said at the
beginning of this i feel like um
you know i'm in my 50s but i feel like
i'm in my 20s because all this death and
all this [ __ ] happened in my life and
all this crazy stuff with my family
and you know and that was a lot of stuff
that was holding me back i'm very
emotional and you know like any of us
are when you're dealing with family it's
it's hard i mean talk about
you know i don't know what you're going
through with your mom with alzheimer's
that's [ __ ] gnarly yeah it's tough
it's [ __ ] gnarly and you know what
they thought you know the tough part
about the past year and a half is
you know it's like i think that like
what this pandemic has done is like i
think we all are dealing with stuff and
we've been dealing with stuff and then
we added this huge thing
that now it was like whoa
this is like too much now all the stuff
that we thought we were handling we
weren't we're not handling well anymore
or we realized that we need to get a
handle on some things you know so i
think it really
made us like
prioritize what's important in our lives
yeah i think you know what's important
is time how do you want to spend your
time
because at the end of the day you know
like my friend jason he just [ __ ] he
owns so much [ __ ] out here he owns
lavo and marquis in
in uh you know tao and all you know him
and his company and they just acquired
you know five or ten more companies and
i'm like yo like yeah you're gonna make
the money but
that's that's four or five more hours of
emails and [ __ ] and employees and you
know what i mean when are you going to
have time to not do anything you know
how people do i think that has to do
with age two though like you know age
has a lot when i was younger i'd want to
do 50 things yeah you know but age and
your parents dying and and where you're
at in your life and me being here like
you know i'm still doing a lot
but i'm not but it's fun stuff and it's
not like stuff i'm making money off of
it's not like all my youtube [ __ ] i'm
making money but i'm having a great time
yeah and i think that's all that matters
and i think that's good man yeah i mean
i do i think that that's like
you know that's the story for all of us
to like follow it's just like hey
what are we doing all this stuff for in
the first place like what's the point of
all this just be happy and i think i've
found a little bit of happiness too and
for myself even during the pandemic just
be like you know i went started gaming
on twitch and i really enjoy doing that
i enjoy the little community of people
that like come watch me every day yeah
you know they're always saying things
and i get messages all the time and i'll
be places and someone will be like yo
man i love you on twitch
and i get i go oh that's something new i
did and then people are you know
acknowledging that so it's like it's
really about staying in your lane and
enjoying what god brought you here for i
mean you're great like i said you before
i said you're an amazing character actor
you know [ __ ] funny dude i mean
people see you
and they go i [ __ ] right right
they're like [ __ ] no they're like [ __ ]
this guy's hilarious he's like a great
great actor and and i love working with
you and um and guest house yeah you know
what i gotta say so much fun you know
what going into that i didn't know what
to expect like if i'm being 100 it was
like even even bobby lee and i had had
conversations where he called me he's
like yo dude are you gonna do this movie
you know and i was like polly keeps
bugging me about it and i'm like you
know and i was like i know he's calling
me too i'm not sure what and i didn't
know because we really hadn't had many
conversations like a lot of interactions
before that but then when i got on set
and sam the director and then how it was
i was like oh i get it it was just like
such a such a fun experience and then
when i saw the and then i still didn't
know what the finished product was gonna
be like but like i gotta i gotta say
it's a really enjoyable movie
like you know what i mean like it's
exactly what you think it is you know
people always ask me what's guest house
about it i just go
paulie shore is living in a couple's
guest house that's
that's it
that's the story and then like an
insanity ensues yeah
i i i get you know a lot of people they
might have that uh preconceived kind of
yeah yeah the people don't know about me
they don't know me and that's okay you
know
bobby's bobby you know with you i
totally understand you know for bobby to
say oh what am i going to do it's like
dude shut the [ __ ] up and do the movie
you're hilarious i've known you for 50
000. you know he's gonna do it yeah but
that's just how he is you know what i
mean but uh um you know bobby you know i
i don't want to say i discovered but i
discovered you know and and you know uh
you know he owes his whole career no he
does not or no you can say it bobby lee
owes his whole career to polly shore
okay there it is right he would have
made it didn't you discover him in like
san diego diego but i had him open for
me when he was terrible and i actually
my mom also last year okay
now when we were when he was first
starting off at the la jolla comedy
store and um i just i saw him and i saw
him in uh i think it was brockton
villars one of his restaurants and there
was a funny like bus boy oh and i was
like oh my god you know what i mean then
we got him at the store and then boom we
just developed him at the store well you
heard it here first breaking news but uh
bobby owes everything to paulie shore
yeah and which means i should be getting
a [ __ ] a check something like the
[ __ ] tiger chinese belly or whatever
right no but he he auditioned for my mom
actually when he was opening for me at
the riviera hotel here in las vegas i
think it was the late 90s and he was
opening for me and he was a comedy store
out here no i was just doing a poly
short show at the at the theater here
and he was my opening act my mom came to
the show and that's when she made him a
paid regular oh wow yeah it was when she
saw him open for me not at the store
because she you know she's very busy and
she you know what i mean but she's
coming to see her son
and she came and and uh did you like
that was it was there something
special about yes [ __ ] my mom did she go
to all you did she do that often i'm
saying i go out of town to see you out
of town was that like one of the first
times or like what was that for you or
the first it's mostly just la jolla or
you know vegas a lot okay because i
played here a lot so um but me and my
mom are very close
like very close
like you know like
best friends like you know that's good
you know like best friends like and we
laughed a lot well that's why it's hard
for me like my mom still has a little
she has her sense of humor in place you
know but it's hard because like when
they're when they're going through that
thing
it's hard to
like sit with her
and know that this is a different person
it's like but here's heart wrenching
every time i go here's some advice that
i'll give you and listening
about slowly watching your parents you
know go
is um and i didn't know this until
[ __ ] she was on hospice
is that
your mom has a neuro neurological kind
of disorder got it but her liver and all
this other [ __ ] in her brain and you
know everything is there it's kind of
functioning
so my my suggestion to you and anyone
else is that
your mom no matter what she says out of
her mouth understands you
so for instance you might go oh she's
like a vegetable now and and this is
uncomfortable but if you lean into her
like this and you go mom i love you i
love you i'm here for you
you kiss her just like as if she wasn't
sick
she feels it and she gets it
because because her her neurological has
nothing to do with her her ears the last
thing that goes for sensory the last
thing that goes is your [ __ ] ears
yeah because the thing that was [ __ ]
about my mom that was so [ __ ] up was
that she um
she couldn't speak
so for instance you knew she wanted to
say something
but she couldn't take what was going on
her [ __ ] brain and put it out in her
mouth and say i want a sandwich
and that's what was [ __ ] yeah
that and imagine how frustrating that is
and her hands were [ __ ] up so she
couldn't write it oh
so she just had to [ __ ] sit there and
knowing hearing all these things that
are going on and what's going on but
just [ __ ] take it and that's that's
the saddest part about parkinson's and
alzheimer's and all that [ __ ] is they're
just there even though inside of them is
fully healthy like my mom's heart was
healthy her livers
you know all this [ __ ] was healthy but
she couldn't communicate because of the
nerve
but the last thing that ghost excuse me
the last thing that goes that was the
barbecue the last thing that goes is
that the throat
because what happens is then you can't
swallow
and if you can't swallow okay then you
stick your tube in there
and then if you you know what what's
that what kind of life is that yeah
so you have to have that that decision
too to deal with so well i know that but
i'd say but that's something my mom had
talked about with me like a long time
ago like being like i see i know i know
she don't she didn't want to be on
machines yeah no one does no one does
well some people but but what i'm saying
is i think that there are choices that
certain family members family members
make because they're being selfish about
themselves you know they're being like i
don't want this person to go or they
want to hold on or whatever i think the
machine is good if like there's a chance
that that person's gonna live and it was
a [ __ ] car crash
and they're like 35 years old right i
get you you know what i mean then you
put the tube in there because you know
what i mean because right now they're
like stuck you know they got in a car
crash and you're stuck like that
but um yeah it's um it's i'll tell you
this there's two different lives there's
a life
when your parents are in it and there's
a life when your parents are not not in
it and they are completely two different
lives and it has no i it has nothing to
do with how old your parents are you
could be like well you know how old your
mom she died at 87. well she had a great
life it has nothing to do with the great
life she's dead she i can't go kiss her
i can't go stop by and bring her you
know soup or whatever so it's yeah it's
tough you know but then another thing
that i realize is your parents don't
want you to mourn you know like my mom
doesn't want me to be sad about her and
my dad doesn't want me to be sad about
them they want me to say hey stop being
a little [ __ ] move on i'm cool you know
they want our parents want us to be
happy yeah i believe that and i feel
like you're
[Music]
you're getting there you're yeah you're
you're or you're living there's no
destination yes
i am now i'm good i'm shifted into that
yeah that's good man yeah yeah it's
tough when this kind of thing happens i
think you know it's like but then we're
at this age now where it's like these
are the things we have to think about
like you know
you know you i think when you hit 40
when you have 40 you don't even realize
hey man
it's coming it's coming to an end this
this phase in your life you know but i
remember when
i got to a point where my mom was no
longer a comfort for me anyway though
you know what i'm saying you know there
was a certain point around no no so he's
passed yeah i don't i just i've never
met my dad
but my stepfather's still in my life
with my mom you know he's there taking
care of her and all that but
you know i just remember part of l.a did
you grow up i grew up in like uh midwest
mid wilshire area
when you say midwell is that cranshawn
wilshire no it's like mid wilshere is
like you know anywhere from like you
know beverly
i'll say think of la brea so anywhere
from everything like
all the way down to like pico got it
okay
but that's like midtown so it's like
midtown mid wilshire went to high school
the mid wilshire area like third street
and all that kind of stuff third in the
excuse me third in la brea so you know
i'm an la guy you know i was born and
raised in l.a like you're we're one of
the few people that we even know around
even like even at the comedy store like
i'm from l.a everybody else is like from
their like whatever city yeah and they
always want to claim they're saying la
like no dude that's 909 bro yeah man
that's like nice
not eight i have a two one three area
code yeah that's original that's la area
yeah what's up guys i'm out in vegas i'm
shooting with him with griffin here and
you know what i gotta tell you something
i miss my
mattress i miss my helix sleep mattress
there is a difference i travel a lot
when you're staying at hotels man
it's it's just you can feel it in your
back you can feel it in your
comfortability
and i'm i'd listen i i really recommend
you get a helix sleep mattress you're
going to get
200 off you're going to get some free
pillows if you use the code griffin eric
griffin.com
i'm sorry it's sleep.com
griffin so make sure you guys go to that
you know uh healing sleep you know the
best thing about it is you take this
sleep quiz and they match you to the
perfect mattress of how you sleep your
body type all of that it's a perfect
situation uh if you're looking for a
mattress i highly recommend it i really
recommend helix sleep um
yeah you know it's like you don't got to
go to the mattress store i mean it's
like i always say this it's like
e-harmony for
mattresses you know it's tinder for you
and your mattress you're gonna swipe on
the perfect one because you're gonna put
all your information but anyways make
sure you go to helixsleep.com
griffin for the 200 off and the
discounts and
i highly recommend it take it from me
eric griffin let's get back to the show
um
but um yeah so i don't know while you're
out here in vegas
how long do you think but it's yeah how
long do you think you're gonna be out
here in vegas
because i think even you know you're not
going to stay here
i agree you know
but i don't know if it means you're
going to go back to l.a but like where
where like what's next i mean have you
ever lived in new york i love new york
have you ever lived in heart no i have
not
i love new york yeah you seem like new
york's got my heart yeah i think you do
well out of new york
really yeah yeah that's probably my next
place yeah you'll have like a you'll
have like a
a cult of
just that those kind of people you like
having around you are gonna be they're
they're all over the place in new york
yeah very bohemian yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like the village and yeah i always
really like i spent a lot of time in new
york you know my all my life i would
always go out there and you know when i
when i got my gig on mtv especially mtv
was new york based yeah yeah so we used
to go out there all the time and do
shows i had photos of me and chappelle
at the [ __ ] stoney awards 20
something years ago when i hosted that
and that was [ __ ] awesome and
and just you know new york is is is got
that you know all the artists you know
and that's the issue with vegas is i
don't find that and that's the thing
that'll probably drive me out right you
know it's not like uh yeah because you
were like you took me to like what you
said this is the art district and i was
like mechanic shop mechanic shop
mechanic shop pawn shop and then there
was like one nice oh our antique store
and you're like look at this
the art district
it'll be it'll be there soon you'll see
yeah this area that area the arts
district in vegas is coming up it's cool
it's not there yet but there's i mean
i'll name some sick places for the lows
you locals you got esther's kitchen you
got with the vegan taco shop you got uh
the sushi bar across the street that's
amazing i forgot the name um
you got makers and finders you got
public u.s you got really cool well that
barbecue place we went to today what's
the name of the place uh soul belly soul
belly and they had it's just three
o'clock in the afternoon on a sunday and
they had this great three-piece like
blues band playing live
singing dude was like a dude look like
he was fresh out of prison right just
jamming on a harmonica
you know and they were singing all these
like bluesy country songs and i was like
this is great yeah no it's six people in
there not even that just like enjoy this
but it's like amazing like you know no
the arts district for um you got you got
the vegas trip here you got downtown
here and the arts district is right in
the middle and then um keith keith
stubbs who owns uh wise guys in utah's
uh i hooked him up with my friend jason
they own the land and i organized that
whole deal so wise guys is going to be
opening here in vegas on september 7th
and he's already got a whole bunch of
comics booked and it's a [ __ ] awesome
road room so it's the first comedy club
in las vegas that you don't have to take
a [ __ ] escalator or a [ __ ] listing
or park over there or go you know what i
mean
it's a stand alone but i feel like
that's going to be sort of a like a
locals absolutely right yeah but i think
that the tourists are going to hear
about it and hear that like spade is
playing there or someone you're playing
there or whoever and they're going to
[ __ ] go like oh [ __ ] i want to go
check that out and they're going to see
this new area the arts district and the
arts district also has sidewalks
everywhere most vegas there's not a lot
of sidewalks yeah they don't want you
walking they want you like you know they
want you on a move a people mover right
to a crap table right
um
but you know i'm here you know ryan's
here who's shooting this and i've been
filming a lot of great stuff out of here
i know it might not be for you but i'm
enjoying it
no no no no we just don't even you know
i love you man yeah i think i think i
think like i say i enjoy watching you
enjoy yourself yeah that's my favorite
thing about you yeah my favorite thing
about you was like you'll have like
seven
weirdos around you and they and you you
know what i mean like
no offense ryan
no but you're a professional so that's
why you know you have a skill yeah some
of these people here some of these
people he has around i'm like what does
that girl do or what does that guy do
but he just is like you know like he's
like the weirdo whisperer you know what
i mean and then he's just there with his
little cult and they're just like they
love him and they appreciate him and
you're just having a great time
so i think that that's like you know
it's something to be said about just you
know like you've it's funny to to to be
where you are right now to like as
opposed to like where you started like
because you were talking about mtv
earlier do you ever like flip on mtv and
just be like damn what what is this now
like you know because like
i mean i think back to those days and
i'm like my god mtv was like one of the
biggest things ever it was the biggest
thing you know what i mean yeah you know
you were doing stadiums off that [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah so it's like
in that now it's like
yeah i don't yeah i don't watch it but
you know the good part about
the internet and kind of the this thing
of what's going on is for for the
artists like us even the people that
aren't artists but you know speak on
behalf of the artist you can do whatever
you want and say whatever you want and
put out whatever you want so that
yeah you can cultivate your own you want
yeah
it is it's kind of cool like it is a
nice thing to learn even if it's not a
lot of people watching but as an artist
i get this [ __ ] out here
and i get it out i have my band probably
showing the crusties i got uh my
sweating with the weasel you play an
instrument no i sing i'm the singer
well no i've been singing since i was
little i'm not good i'm not good but i
have fun
you know i enjoy it probably showing the
crusties
yeah yeah well we're going to be playing
vegas be playing a chinese restaurant in
vegas before no time here yeah yeah we
got it is that your goal a chinese
restaurant yeah is that like just is
that like the starter ground
no that's where it finishes
because again it's all about the comedy
all i give a [ __ ] about is the comedy
that's that's your chinese restaurant
residency that's what you want to get
yeah but people probably people are in a
buffet line you're gonna be like up
there it's not unusual to be loved by
paulie sure doing courtney
now that sounds about right yeah that's
what i'm doing really yes
corbin's fun for me i get it and it's
fun to hear p it's like it's it's almost
like borat i mean you do it you know i'm
playing this part i'm not a homeless guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean that's
what oh you know what i was just about
to say that i think what i enjoy the
most
because not knowing you more now what i
enjoy the most is that you are aware
of what people think about you
you're fully aware of what's happening
in a moment when you're acting pauly
sure and it's like you're watching them
react and they're reacting like what the
[ __ ] with this guy and you're getting
off on love it's my face yeah it's from
straight so there's people think what
i'm saying is like this is what people
don't know about you and the first time
i knew this about you the very first
time i really understood this was when
you were on my podcast for the first
time and you were like you sat there and
you went all right you know what i'm not
going to be
you made a motion of like
let me just i'm going to be real with
you right now because i know that's what
you want right and that's when i was
like oh this motherfucker's
playing everybody
[Laughter]
it is it's all it's
all focused it's not from it's
deliberate it all is deliberate look at
i came into las vegas and i said to
myself i go
i want to start a band with just a bunch
of old [ __ ] that's it and it's going
to be polisher in the trustees and i
could not find any [ __ ] band so i
settled for this other band who's a good
band but it wasn't that funny to me so
one night i'm at sand dollar which is a
rock club here in vegas and i'm sitting
there watching a show with some friends
and i see these old guys on stage
they're doing like a grateful dead
cupboard [ __ ] and i think you were like
this is it
i get the guys i get their numbers and i
go i need a drummer that's as old as you
guys they're like we got it so they get
me eddie thicket and then i bring my old
guy bill from from la though yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's one of your
weirdos i remember him in there so
that's the band and people are loving it
and i put out songs on on youtube and
everything yeah yeah so when have you oh
so you've played live already no we're
doing the first live show in october oh
wow
it's going to be funny at the same time
but we record our videos maybe that
should come open listen yeah we record
our videos in the garage so it's a
garage band with paula's showing these
old [ __ ] guys
but i get it though get it it's a garage
band people think oh you're doing grunge
music no no we film it in a garage
so we're in the garage and i have
wardrobe i play elton john so i put on
the elton john outfit so you just wear
your regular
[Laughter]
and then we got um we got a a
series called classic scenes from
classic movies
which is basically um oh that's
hilarious
you don't even have to tell me what it
is because just
all i hear is
like if it's like paulie sure as the
godfather exactly paulie
out of here and that's been [ __ ]
great and it's a way it's a way to
produce it's a way for me as an actor to
act because that's what i am i'm an
actor without having to call up other
actors and yeah yeah yeah let's do this
so i'm able to edit it in a way and
produce in a way where emotionally i'm
able to get out my chops so i don't
become you know dormant you know when
you don't work on that acting muscle you
know and you're not in class or you're
not doing a movie you got to do
something to to sharpen that thing so
that did that
and i really enjoy that and then i have
my sweat and with the weez thing because
everyone says i'm like richard simmons
so what i do is i do a video called
sweating with the wheeze where i do um
you know workout like a three minute
workout in my backyard you know with my
girl and and we do that and that's
really fun too sweating with the wheeze
[Laughter]
well because people like email or tweet
i mean you look like richard simmons you
do kind of have a little richard simmons
vibe going on right just go with it i'm
like all right [ __ ] it do you have like
do you do you sell merch
i do but i'm just like again it's how do
i want how do i want to spend my days i
want to spend hours dealing with my
merch i'm a merch guy you got a guy
friend you got a camera guy you got a
[ __ ]
old man you got a thing you know it's
like you know this is this is what this
is like you know this is how you know
he's financially okay by the way because
it ain't even a thing because weezer
shirts would still sell and all the you
know
you know you know all that stuff i did
sell it i just don't make it a big deal
to sell it they're coming at me to do my
own marijuana strain so that's like the
next thing that oh my god i don't know
smoke weed and that makes sense to you
you don't want to smoke some weed get
some wheats you know
[Laughter]
weeds legal here yeah i don't think it
did it would it have mattered to you
no
[Music]
were you like you know if you don't have
to talk about if you don't want to but
like when you were coming up and it was
like 80s and 90s were you like did you
try every drug possible
or was that something you stayed away
from i'm curious not to say that like
your persona would come across like you
took a lot of drugs but i could
understand if you didn't i did coke once
in a once in a while but it was never i
went on a coke binge it wasn't like
let's do cokes like i'd do a little and
then i'd be good is that something you
got from like the comedy store because
those are the stories you hear all the
time it's like it was like just
you know that back that that that that
that uh glass piano back there is where
everybody did code it was like you know
it wasn't really the store it was it was
my friends that i went to school with
because i went to beverly hills high
school so as you know beverly hills high
school i mean you guys went to l.a yeah
that's where it gave you beverly hills
high school in the 80s was it was a
[ __ ] you know it was less than zero
yeah casino was based off beverly hills
high school yeah it wasn't like the
[ __ ] show
but it was like a john hughes film i
mean beverly hills high school was just
it was heaven it was [ __ ] heaven from
like 9th grade to 12th grade was like
i mean
you know we would skateboard empty
swimming pools we'd [ __ ] go you know
get in fights with vowels on the [ __ ]
bus we'd go [ __ ] mortgage more boogie
boarding we'd you know put zinc oxide on
our noses we'd smoke weed we'd go to the
westwood comedy store and play the
arcade and watch [ __ ] you know
jim carrey do this [ __ ] thing or
whatever and and uh you remember
westworld i'm sure you went to westwood
growing up yeah yeah and [ __ ] was the
best yeah that's where like remember
that was like we're the only place to
really go see movies back in the day too
that was like the the whole you know
they would like and then like if there
was a movie premiere they would change
the whole city and hold the whole
downtown and be like oh we're making the
gotham city because batman's coming out
or you know westwood but westwood
village was like you know in high school
was like the coolest place in the world
i mean it was just you know look at that
fair they would do every year
like out there on the on that big
fairground i forgot what it was called
where you see like ucla remember that
the sickest yeah that would be like oh
my
god in like weird amusement park
because you can meet girls from pally
the palisades girls yeah yeah yeah
because you know it'd be like this this
ucla there was like you know like you
said affair and all the kids from all
the different schools would all meet
there yeah i used to do this thing i
forgot what it was called though mardi
gras was it called mardi gras i feel
like it you know that was one that was
in my head too i thought it was mardi
gras but it was like a a particular name
yes that's crazy and they would and it
would be every year and it would be like
food and and rides and rides and all
kinds of stuff and that'd be the thing
to do we got to go to ucla and go do
that i used to ride the bus by myself
yeah even when i even to go to the
movies when i was a kid i'd be like 13
or something you know what i mean just
take the yeah take the bus down wilshire
off at the federal building yeah exactly
yeah
[ __ ] man um but yeah vegas is cool it's
kind of where i'm at now you know it's
definitely not la you know la is sad to
me right now there's a sadness there
there's a resistance there there's a you
know a very woke kind of like thing
there and that energy it just doesn't
work for me right now i mean i
understand people are there and they're
they're going through what they're going
through and that's fine but for where
i'm at in my life
it doesn't really work for me i felt
like guest house was a throwback to like
a movie that like their people seem to
be afraid to make right now you know
because it's just like you know boys
being boys and like you know you know
tna and just raunchiness and language
and you know just you know just just
what comedy what comedy used to be about
you know uh the the fun lighter side of
it and now i think you know it's like
now we have to make you know just sad
depressing movies or there could be no
victims in the movie like you can't have
a victim anymore like a female can't be
a victim someone of color can't be a
victim uh you know you can't we can't
have nudity we can't have like you know
so
i mean i i understand that there's like
you don't want to be like gluttonous
with these types of things but there is
something based in comedy where all
those things can be funny and like even
like that show that i was on even like
show like workaholics i don't know if
workaholics would work right now if if
it came out just because of you know it
was drugs and women and uh you know you
know just the some of the subject matter
that they made silly people now would be
like this is this is problematic and
toxic to behavior so that you know so
what do you think about you know are you
being able to make a movie like you did
called like guest house and is that the
direction you want to go in or is it
just like not
or are you just like hey i'm just going
to do my own fun stuff because i don't
want to deal with the hollywood no no i
want to deal with the hollywood machine
you know i'm all about ideas i think
guesthouse was just a good idea
you know when he when sam came to me
with the concept
you know um and said hey this is what it
is i'm like you're in the guest house
i'm like that's [ __ ] hilarious and
that's why i glommed on it and i helped
rewrite the script yeah and i helped
soften the character because the
original character was very kind of
harsh and i made my guy a lot more
likeable and there was a reason why you
know you find out at the end why he was
going so crazy they want to let go of
his house yeah you know there's all this
stuff so
the idea was it's always about the idea
so for me
if someone comes up to me with an idea
that i think is really good i don't care
what time
you know it is and then if someone wants
to put up the money then like let's go
you met him you know yeah let's rock and
roll you know the house was you know
right time right movie right place write
this right that you know what i mean and
it did well and people liked it and yeah
people did like it so yeah still on
netflix now so check out netflix check
out guest house on netflix and uh it is
what it is myself yeah star polly
shortly yeah and we were from how much
time we've been right now
well it's been about 40 minutes perfect
we're gonna go i got ten more minutes
and we're good man this is great i love
it
what's on scale yeah man you're like i
say like you know i wish
i i don't know if you sometimes i feel
like i don't know if you want people to
know
the lighter side of yourself or like the
more vulnerable side of your personality
maybe i feel like
it's like
exclusive to
like close friends and family but like
you know why is that
um
because
i like to laugh
you know what i mean i like to be silly
and to be serious and real and [ __ ] is
like
i don't know
you know
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah like
i have a gift god gave me a gift like
you know i can i'm he gave me the gift
of to be make people laugh and so like i
like to lean into that because
you know i like making people laugh you
know what i mean i don't want to make
people cry yeah you know and be all
serious and [ __ ] i like being
i like people thinking i'm stupid or i
like people thinking that i'm you know
one way you know
i don't care um i'm sure like you got
you get this a lot because i get this
even myself on my small scale i i really
enjoy when people send me messages about
like hey thanks for
putting out content and doing what you
do
because in the past year it really
helped me get through
you know and that really made me really
realize like really how important what
we do is
yeah like i said like i have a gift you
have a gift like anyone can be serious
and be real and like thought provoking
and like and all like heady and [ __ ] but
like not anyone could be funny
you know what i mean and me and you i
love doing schtick with you
you know me and like i'm like i just
think like and everyone says the same
thing you guys got to do a move i'm like
great give us a [ __ ] script and a
budget and a budget and tell us when to
show we got a camera guy he could be our
dp well we're ready to go but what's
this movie gonna be yeah so um yeah
we've got that we got a gift of making
people laugh so i'd rather be sillier
than be serious i guess yeah you know
you know that [ __ ] on the street was
hilarious with that dude yeah some
random guy just make sure you check out
paulie's instagram yeah uh all his
information will be below check out his
instagram you'll see you'll see a thing
that we did we're probably dressed the
same uh the uh yeah some weird guy just
walks up and like i i love that it's
like because you've been in the business
so long you have a wide range of people
who know who you are but like you could
tell this is a guy that knew you you
know for a while he's known you for a
while for a while you know what i mean
and he's just like polish
and he's like you know he's into it yeah
man and that always at any time i go
anytime if somebody's really into you
i'm like let me see what's going on with
this person because they don't really
you know i mean they don't really know
what they're super into yeah it's okay
you know they don't have to know the
serious side of me you know i get it
it's [ __ ] yeah but that'll be your
thing though like i you know this is
like happens to everybody it's like you
know you're gonna have like like you're
gonna play
that like robin williams part in uh uh
good will hunting or something like
maybe there is a role out there where
people are gonna be like and then that's
gonna be the thing a side of pauly shore
you've never seen you know what i mean
and that'll be the thing that really
shows because ultimately being an actor
because even being doing comedy is
acting even uh when we're on stage
performing we're for we're acting
we're performing you know absolutely
like don't fool yourself we're
performing even if it's a part of our
personality we're still performing we're
performing you know so there is
something about being in a show or a
movie where you can like because people
ask me all the time what do you prefer
acting or stand up you know and i hate
making that choice
because there is something about taking
material i like acting better you do oh
really yeah i like acting better but i
agree with you but i've seen your set so
i understand why but go on
that was harsh right too hard that was
that too hard
so yeah so acting to me is is way more
because it's very detailed and it's very
specific and it's it's this and it's a
lot of prep yeah yeah i know exactly
it's a lot of prep like i prepped my ass
off for guest house yeah i prep like all
the little things and yeah and you know
and people wouldn't think that people
would think it's like oh what does he
just show up and be pauly shore and it's
like they don't know like how even these
little you know guys what you don't even
know i mean let you a little inside of
paulie shore right now even these little
man on the street things that he's doing
you don't know how much
he
very much
i want you to do this this this this and
this i'm going to say this you try to
say this and then try to make it natural
and then it comes out when you think ah
look at paulie just being paulie but no
man it's all deliberate it's all you
know planned out and and i think that's
like you know that's what's great about
doing things for youtube and instagram
and stuff and so you can combine this
like stand up energy but we're like oh i
can do some acting and do something so
that's why i like about one of my
favorite shows is curb your enthusiasm i
mean i haven't watched every episode but
i just love larry david because you know
like he's playing he's playing um a role
of a guy after his career and this is
who he is now and his his acting and how
he exaggerates and like it's coming from
a true place but it's all fake yeah yeah
and like the stuff with you we do this
thing on the thing where i'm asking him
to move to [ __ ] vegas because joe
rogan's got everyone to move too you
know people are going to like the the
the comments are going to be like dude
don't move to vegas it's disgusting
oh yeah you should but it's all i don't
say it's fake but it's all acting we're
active
this is not acting yeah i don't just i
don't dislike him yeah
no another video you might think uh yeah
no so um
kurt i love the curb style and i love i
love i love interacting with with comic
great comedic actors in that way because
it's fun dude it's easy but you know i
find you know okay so i've you know i
did workaholics i've done like some i've
done some funny things you know but i
will say like when i was doing i'm dying
up here
there was something about
coming from a commit comedic
uh background
but doing this sort of real grounded
dramatic thing
i found it very rewarding great even
even more so than like doing some funny
thing absolutely you know what i mean
yeah if people ask me and i'm sure maybe
it's not probably you too i don't know
if they say if i had one thing that i
could do in my career like what would be
the one thing and that'd be like to do
like a a like a third lead in a dramatic
film with a really good director yeah
that would be like my number one and i
tell my [ __ ] manager all the time i'm
like
but the problem is they have such short
v they have such limited vision the
people that sometimes are people that
run hollywood because because they think
they think of you all the time it's like
well you're not you can't be serious
you're always going to be this guys that
are great directors like a clinton or
you know i mean i use him as a
very generic
kind of
simple thing because people understand
it but you get a guy who's who has a
vision who has control has some [ __ ]
balls and also um people respect if
quentin tiernon tarantino says i want
eric griffin to play this [ __ ]
detective in a in this thriller thing
that winds up later that he's the killer
you know or some [ __ ] like that you know
he would do it you know what i mean
let's let's start that hashtag right now
no but that to me it's like because i
think comedians love to act yeah we do
they know how to act but not a lot of
actors can do comedy except for de niro
i think de niro kind of you know what's
funny about what de niro does is i think
de niro is still doing what de niro does
in serious movies and it but it's what
the people around him are reacting to
but him doing what he does and it's just
perfect but he's aware of it yes comedy
though yes when he does analyze this and
he's working with ben stiller or
whatever you know comedic actors he
still knows he's in a comedy right but i
agree with you but he's still but he's
still being a mob boss correct
you know what i mean yeah i mean
and that's why i love classic scenes
from classic movies because it kind of
you know if all hell if all fails i can
at least do that
and i can play these roles you know as
if i got you know
uh people versus larry flint
you know what i mean right and it's
great and they turned out great and if
you watch it people like [ __ ] and where
can they find that it's on my youtube
and my instagram yeah so check out
paulie's youtube check out his instagram
yeah check out classic scenes from
classic movies and check out uh
uh sweating with the wiis and polish on
the crusties and also my podcast random
rants yeah i've been on i've been on
random rants yeah that was fun yeah you
had like yeah he's got random people on
random rants around him it's like that
was so much fun listen man i appreciate
you uh doing this for me because i'm out
here in vegas i'm you know you know i
was at brad garrett's all week and i was
like i got to do my podcast i was like
do it solo so it's better this is always
better i always enjoy being around you i
enjoy your energy yeah yeah you know
what i mean i think yeah it's always a
good thing i think a lot of it has to do
with her both from la too so yeah
respect too yeah but i also think
there's some sort of like there's a
comedian bond that
all comedians kind of have like a
commonality there's a thing there that
they go oh i get what you've been
through i get i get how your brain works
to to figure out how to make something
funny there's something there that we're
connected that way we're not all close
we're not all friends we don't even like
each other but there's a there's a
common bond there
but when you actually do like the person
it makes it
stronger and you have a good friendship
you know because it's like you know
we're starting a you know second half
second part of our lives called the back
nine you know what i mean we're living
like so many i think you know i think
about we live so many different lives in
our lifetime you know you have your
childhood you have like
your adult you know you're different
when you're like in high school to like
in your college years and then you're
your 30s you live all these lifetimes i
think back now about man i was doing
such different things and now i'm
starting a completely new life i'm
engaged and you know it's like i'm like
what the hell am i starting moving in
vegas
but anyway this has been paulie shore
this is riffing with griffin on the road
special edition style they're filming
with griffin yeah go ahead what you want
to do well they like it a lot of the
kids yeah griffin with griffin bro oh
you know what i mean yeah
dude you bought me this house bro come
on i feel you but there's a lot of
people right now googling paulie sure
i'll see you next week
[Music]